foreign
ly my policy to uh not talk about
Chelsea Handler at all that's an easy
rule to abide by given that she rarely
does or says anything worth talking
about but this week after her Daily Show
episode which very unpersuasively touted
the wonders of childlessness
um I was forced to violate that policy
and now today in a truly unprecedented
moment in the history of the show I will
violate it for the second time in a week
uh after some of us in conservative
media critiqued her pitch for the
childless lifestyle Handler has now
fired back with another video and her
rebuttal of course does not actually
address any of the points that we made
instead she just lobs insults but that's
not what I find objectionable okay I'm
not above lobbing an insult or two
myself on occasion as we just covered my
my real problem is that the insults are
as we've come to expect from his Handler
witness and unimaginative and boring
uh let's watch
hey everyone I woke up this morning well
more like this afternoon and
seating hairline Society to discuss a
comedy video I filmed about not wanting
kids
wow why would I even need my own
children when I get to hear these cry
babies all the time I mean I can't
believe that bearded version of Tucker
Carlson thinks I would take a half a
bottle of Xanax I'd take way more than
that you silly goose look I don't want
to debate whether or not I'm a girl boss
although I did just look at my bank
account and think that's pretty girl
boss and then I thought about the 10
different people plus 10 plus different
people I've been able to put through
college and then I remembered my six New
York Times best-selling books or was it
five oh no no it was six and then I
remember my recent stand-up special that
was just released on Netflix called
Revolution and I thought yeah you are a
girl boss you guys seemed so triggered
by me I mean my goodness Tucker I think
it is time for you to ask yourself a
serious question are you really upset
about how much freedom I have or are you
upset that you haven't been able to take
it away from me yet oh and quick shout
out to Ben Shapiro thank you for helping
my cause of not having children who
needs the birth control pill when your
voice is 100 effective I don't need a
husband Ben because I'm in a
relationship with myself and at least in
my relationship someone can get a woman
to and by all means Tucker if you want
to respond to my triggers I will be
happy to keep putting out videos as long
as you want I think we both know that
you are a hate masturbating to me and
I'm down with that
okay let's uh review a few things here
Chelsea first of all
saying that you shouldn't have the
freedom to be childless it's not about
freedom I mean not exactly I mean you
did kill your three children in order to
achieve your childhood status and I
don't think that you should have had the
freedom to do that but nobody's saying
that women should be forced to conceive
children if you want to be a lonely
spinster that is your prerogative
we're simply offering our opinion about
statements you made and opinions you
expressed on National Television in
front of a live studio audience
um and it was not just a comedy video it
was in fact a 10-minute rant about being
childless a rant which contained nothing
that anyone with a sense of humor could
recognize as comedy but comedy or not
you brought up the subject you submitted
your private life for public
consideration and we took it into
consideration we did exactly what you
wanted us to do you wanted us to think
about and talk about you it's just that
you also wanted to control what we think
and say and that's where it all breaks
down you see it doesn't work that way
Chelsea you can make yourself the center
of attention but you cannot exercise
control over the manner of the attention
you receive so you can stand on the
rooftops and Shout look at my lifestyle
isn't it great
but you can't force us to answer yes to
that question
as we're all aware the left is giving up
common sense and has crazy ideologies
this Lent we're gonna combat that with a
solid foundation in faith values and
standing up above their hypocrisy with
one starting on Ash Wednesday February
22nd there is no better time to build a
habit of prayer and meditation to stay
rooted than now pray every single day
leading up to Easter on hallow the
number one Christian Prayer app in the
U.S helps me maintain a daily prayer
routine and it can help you to download
the app for free at hello.com Matt Walsh
you can set prayer reminders and track
your progress along the way not sure
where to start we'll check out father
Mike schmitz's Bible in a year available
on the hollow app for brief daily Bible
readings and Reflections or you can pray
alongside Mark Wahlberg and even some
world-class athletes with Halo you can
customize a personal prayer plan that
works for you listen on the way to work
on a plane in the morning or at night
with downloadable offline sessions and
customized uh lengths with with anywhere
from one to 60 Minute options stay
rooted in your faith and your values and
make this year your year for spiritual
growth and peace get an exclusive
three-month free trial at hollow.com
Matt Walsh that's howlo.com slash Matt
Walsh
second predictably your entire rebuttal
aside from complaining that people are
talking about you even after you did
everything in your power to get us to
talk about you consists of insulting the
looks of your critics and making crass
comments about their sex lives and so on
I wasn't surprised by this because it is
the standard left-wing feminist response
to literally all criticism and since you
included me in the receding hair uh
committee I'm a ranking member I might
add let me try to explain something to
you it's just important so tip you can
take with you uh you know for the rest
of your life
um I'm a married man in my late 30s with
six kids Ben is a married man with kids
so are Jesse Kelly and Tucker Carlson
you aren't going to hurt us by telling
us that we're unattractive and the
reason is simply that we don't need you
to find us attractive as men see we're
all about utility and efficiency and
practicality which means that we're
secure in the knowledge that we each
only needed to find one woman who for
whatever inexplicable reason found us
physically appealing and we did so we
won the game
the opinion of other women especially a
woman like yourself is rendered totally
irrelevant
now
on the other hand
if you are say a single 47 year old
woman who looks and sounds like a 65
year old lifelong smoker
then glaring physical deficiencies can
potentially become a real problem
see Chelsea none of the people involved
in this dispute neither the men you name
nor you yourself would qualify as
physically beautiful
but only one of us is alone with our
mediocre appearance
third Chelsea if you're really happy
then there's nothing we can say to
convince you otherwise and we aren't
trying to convince you of anything yet
Society is full of people constantly
dancing in the streets waving pom-poms
in the air shouting into megaphones
about how how they're you know so proud
of themselves and so happy with their
lifestyle choices
you're just one in a large crowd
carrying on this way
I can't help but notice that there's a
certain and unmistakable insecurity to
the whole routine
if you're truly happy with how you've
chosen to live and confident in those
choices then you wouldn't feel the need
to announce the fact
and you certainly wouldn't get all bent
out of shape by people who criticize you
and respond to the video insulting on
looks and listing your professional
achievements I mean you're in your
original segment in order to convince us
that you're happy you showed us photos
from your Instagram
because of course we all know that
nobody's ever painted a misleading and
Rosy picture of their own lives on
Instagram indeed Instagram is renowned
for giving totally unvarnished and
completely accurate insights into the
lives of others everyone knows that if
somebody looks happy on Instagram they
must be really happy people we all know
that
and then in this video you added to your
happiness resume by talking about your
Netflix special and your best-selling
books
I'm beginning to detect a whiff of this
desperation here Chelsea
I don't believe that you're really all
that happy
and what's more I don't believe that you
believe it
our culture is full of people trying to
convince themselves that they're happy
by convincing everyone else first it's a
sad spectacle to watch frankly
and if I keep watching I'll wind up as
sad as you
so instead I will leave you to your
pretend happiness and simply say you are
today canceled that'll do it for the
show today as we move over to the
members block if you want to become a
member you can use code Walsh at
checkout for two months free on all
annual plans hope to see you over there
if not talk to you on Monday uh or
rather on Tuesday because it's
President's Day
Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign